dure fin de campagne pour simone veil il
hier soir elle n'a guère pu parler de
l'europe les deux réunions débats
qu'elle devait tenir à paris ont en
effet été perturbé par des commandos
d'extrême droite du front national de
jean marie le pen jean-marie le pen qui
étaient là en personne rue lepic où les
incidents ont été les plus violents
[Applaudissements]
après tout a dégénéré la bagarre est
devenu général les chaises et les points
ont volé bas les militants des fonds
national se sont déchaînés poussant des
hurlements lançant des autorités bombe
lacrymogène des fumigènes la police un
moment débordé et tout de même
intervenus pour rétablir l'ordre
elle a interpellé vie jeunes gens des
incidents dans le fond national qui
manifestaient pour la liberté
d'expression rejette la responsabilité
sur les amis de madame veil et que
monsieur tixier vignancour au nom de la
liste à droite a condamné ce matin sans
réserve
en tout cas madame v hier soir a dû
partir en catimini et la troisième
réunion qu'elle devait tenir dans le 20e
arrondissement a été annulé
[Musique]